PAUL IRISH: Hello,
hi, so I'm going
to show a little bit around
using the Chrome Developer
tools and how to have
a productive workflow
in developing, also
capturing developing
for the mobile web and some
more performance stuff.
So first up, we're going
to dive into workflow,
and so optimizing
how fast we can
iterate when we're
doing development.
To do this, I'm going to demo.
And so I'm going to try
and put this in my pocket.
How's that?
Does that work?
OK, that's not awkward at all.
All right, so we're going
to come out to this.
This is a site that I work
on with some friends called
HTML5 Please.
And let's say I just want to
make some changes on this site.
So I'm just hosting it.
I have a local server
on localhost:8000.
And I want to make some changes.
All right, so let's
see, I'm going
to open up the Chrome
Developer tools,
select this, and
make some changes.
Maybe I'm going to bring the
font size down a little bit,
add in a new color-- it
doesn't look very good.
Let me try-- I'll
change this over
to blue for now-- OK, sure.
Now normally how this works is
that I will take this and take
the changes that I like, and
copy them, and then come over
to my text file-- say it's right
here-- and paste it in, right?
And that's how I would
probably normally do it.
But that's not very good.
So what we can actually do
is we can combine the two.
And so what we're
going to do is use
a new feature called Workspaces.
And this allows me
to kind of mount
in my code, my local
development folder, into Chrome
and just be able to save
directly back to disk
with all my changes.
So this is how it works.
First, I'll just
refresh the page.
OK, and now I right click
in the Sources panel.
And I can select Add
Folder to Workspace.
So everyone can see
this-- down there.
Now, that comes up.
And I want to select what
folder I'm going to bring in.
And here's my local
folder for this project.
So I say, Yes and Allow.
All right, now we
can see it here.
And so here's my local folder.
And so this has
everything, all the
files in it, say, for
instance, my configuration
for Sass, my gitignore.
I can make any changes here.
And also, if, say
for instance, I
make a new file,
that also comes in.
And I can see that.
So hello, hello,
and then-- right.
So, nice, I have a mapping
between what I have on disk
and what I have inside
Chrome in full persistence.
The way this gets
interesting is being
able to manipulate the
styles, or whatever else,
like we all want to.
So let's do some of that.
So I was making some
changes here before.
And then, we'll bring down this
font size and select this guy.
We'll change him--
ooh, that's pretty.
That's nice.
I like this.
So that's good.
And now, when I come over
to-- ah, one mistake.
One thing that I need to do
once I mount in this folder
is to map it.
I need to map it
to my other assets.
So I have my script that's
coming from local host.
But I need to tell Chrome
than it needs to match.
So what I do-- this
is a one-time set-up--
I need to map file
to local resource.
So I select the
one that matches.
And that's it-- yes.
OK, OK, now I'm going
to come back and make
this change again.
And I'll add in a new color.
And now when I come
over to my code,
you can see my font
size is now 3M.
My color is blue.
I'll add in a few more border--
10px, solid gray, background,
hmm, I don't know, green?
Green-- not improvements,
but they're coming right in.
So this is full
persistence in there.
Now, another way I
could do this is I
could come in to the Sources
panel and make any changes.
One new change
that we just added
is if you hold down
the Alt key, you
can now just hold down Alt
and change these numbers
just right with Up and Down.
So I can make changes here.
Or I could come over
to my text editor
and-- say I don't
like green anymore.
I really want purple.
I hit Save in Sublime.
And I come back here, and it's
like, oh sure, no problem.
So this is really nice.
If you do want to continue
to develop over here and make
any changes, it'll just
come in immediately.
So this is pretty powerful.
And I've showed
it with CSS here.
But it's also really
useful with JavaScript.
So on this site, if
I type in this box,
we filter down the
results of what's
showing up here based on that.
But if I want to get a better
understanding of how that
works-- maybe I want
to add some console log
like debug statements
to figure this out.
So let me just close these.
I'm going to hit Command-O
and look for my script file.
And yeah, actually
this is perfect.
So right now, when
I type here, I
want to get an idea of
how these values come
into the JavaScript
that's handling this.
So what I can just
do is immediately
enter in a console
log statement.
And so I'm in the
Update Search Method.
And so I'm just going
to blog that I'm there
and see what the value is.
Now, when I hit Command-S right
now, what Command-S is doing is
it's persisting
this change to disk.
And then, it's also telling
V8, the JavaScript engine,
that it needs to now
evaluate this new definition
of this file.
So I'm hitting Command-S. I'm
not refreshing the page at all.
And when I type here,
it immediately changes.
So V8 has a new definition.
And now, if I go over, and
I'll just double check,
here's my changes that I
made to disk on the styles.
Yup, and here's my change
down here to the JavaScript.
So this is nice, because
I can go really fast.
I'm not refreshing the page.
I'm changing both
CSS and JavaScript
and persisting all the
changes that I like to disk.
One thing I didn't show is--
let's see if this works.
We have full undo and redo.
So I'm going to try-- oh
no, I refreshed the page.
Damn, all right, so if
I make these changes,
and I don't really
like them, I can just
hit Command-Z to
bring them back.
So whether you make changes here
inside the DevTools or changes
over here, you can
just hit Command-Z
to kind of work your way back.
And all those changes will
be maintained in the files.
So this gets really
powerful, right?
I can edit the entire project.
Whether it's mark
down files, PHP files,
I can do it right
there in the DevTools.
So the DevTools kind
of becomes my editor.
All the changes persist
to disk, full undo, redo,
and it's nice because I
can maintain my context.
If I'm setting break points in
my JavaScript in the DevTools,
I can also edit right there
and make those changes
and save those to desk.
All right, the next
thing I want to show
is the DevTools support
for Sass and Less.
Who writes their
styles using Sass?
Raise your hand.
Yes, or Less-- Less, a lot
more people are using Less.
Good, OK, this was just
added like two weeks ago.
But let me show
you how this works.
So now, one thing
that you might notice
is that-- let's say I'm going
to select this little item right
here.
So this is the little-- Use
Item is what I'm selecting.
And if we look over here,
we have a few styles on it.
And we have just this green and
a green that's a little darker,
and a green that's a
little darker than that.
But you can see actually where
this definition is coming from.
It's from an SESS file.
So it's not a Sass file.
It's not a CSS file.
It's an SESS file.
So let me click through on
that and see what's going on.
Oh, let me try that once more.
OK, so here, we're
actually jumping
to the definition of the mix in.
So the mix in that I wrote
for this Sass kind of
does some things.
I have a variable coming
in with this color.
Here's the background box
shot on boarder radius.
But it's taking this color, and
it's kind of darkening it here.
It's darkening it here.
So we're doing some
nice things in the Sass.
But if I want to make a change
to this green, what I could do
is just take this
and change the color.
But that doesn't
really work, right?
I have this stuff here.
So clearly, I'm not going
to be able to do this
by just editing the CSS.
I need to edit the
Sass, the original Sass.
So let's try that.
So if you hold down the
Command key or the Control key,
you'll see an underline.
Let me zoom in on that.
So this command, this
indicates that you
can jump to the original
location where this is defined.
So here, if I Command
click on background,
I jump to where
the background is.
But I want to change the color.
So I want to Command click
on that background color.
And now-- whoops.
Well, what I'm
expecting it to do
is to jump to this
color definition, which
is in my Variables Sass file.
So what's cool here
is if I want to make
this change to this
variable definition-- let's
say I'm going to turn it to
red-- I just hit Command-S,
and I wait.
And I get my changes.
So I just changed
Sass in the DevTools.
And what happened on
the back is over here,
I actually have a tab that
has a little watch, just
to monitor changes, and have
compass and Sass recompile
the new CSS.
And so that happened.
And then, DevTools
picked up on the fact
that the CSS file had changed
and just refreshed it.
So now I can make any sort
of change in the Sass.
And it takes a
little bit of time
to actually-- there we
go-- for the change happen.
But this is really nice.
Because I can go very fast now.
All right, so that is a little
bit of the DevTools support.
Like I mentioned, we've had
support for Sass for awhile.
And the guys behind
the Less project
just added support
inside their compiler
for creating source
maps, which is
what powers this whole thing.
So we have support for both.
So this whole story
really creates
a compelling
development environment
where I can just-- anywhere
that I type, I can style,
see the immediate results.
Everything is
persistent to disk.
And I get a lot of
immediate feedback.
All right, but I want
to take this stuff
and go mobile with it.
So let's do that.
So we're going to
come over here.
And I have my phone.
And this is my password.
All right, so let me
just refresh this.
OK, cool-- focus, yeah, good.
Now I want to do
this development.
And I want to debug
what's on my phone.
So let's try that out.
So I come over to
Chrome Inspect.
You can also just
type, "about inspect."
And now, let's see, I want
to get this on the screen
at the same time.
There we go.
Now let's plug in the phone.
Doo, doo, doo-- yeah,
woo, all right, cool,
so it just found my phone.
Now raise your hand if you've
done a remote debugging
with Chrome on Android before--
OK, cool, a few of you.
Before, it required some
things around downloading
the entire Android SDK.
It was really painful.
Now, just plug it in.
It just works.
So we see Chrome.
Chrome 31 is now here.
And I want to load a page.
So let's see, I don't
know, load naver.com, sure.
All right, cool-- all right, so
I'm just going to hit Inspect.
And all right, here's the
DevTools, the full DevTools.
And so if I come
over to Timeline,
and I start a recording,
and I scroll the page,
I'm getting all that stuff.
So that's really cool.
Raise your hand if you have
one of these cameras here
that can take a picture of your
camera and put it on your-- OK,
probably not.
So we thought that
this is a problem.
So let's solve this.
So I'm going to kill this video.
And I'm going to
go into Settings
and turn on a new experiment
that we've been working on.
This is called Screencast.
This is the first time that
I've ever showed this publicly.
So this is the debut
of this feature.
I'm really excited.
All right, so what we do is we
close that down and bring that
back up.
Ahh, and now-- yes.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: So this
is really cool.
So I have-- as I just
scroll, I can see immediately
what's going on.
So I can just do the same thing.
Right, so that's really nice.
I don't have to go back
and look down at the phone
and come over here.
Because it's all right
here on the screen.
So let's do a search.
So I can type and
be like, Chrome.
OK, but this is taking a while.
I'd much rather just
type here on my keyboard.
So let's try that.
Ah, OK, cool, so I can type.
And let's see.
Let's check.
Yeah, all right, I can click.
And the last thing
I want to show here
is that I can just Inspect
Element, and Inspect Element
works, too.
So I can just select the item.
And my DOM view comes up.
So this is really powerful.
This means that I don't
have to go and muck back
with my device.
I have it all right
here on screen.
And I have the full
DevTools to support it.
But let's go back to the project
that I was developing before.
It was this, localhost:8000.
And so we'll just open up a
tab with that and inspect it.
Hmm, so one thing-- there we go.
So one thing that happens a
lot is that you want to develop
localhost:8000.
But your phone doesn't know
what localhost:8000 is.
Because that's your machine.
So the feature that
we have available
now is port forwarding.
So you can just say, I want
whatever's on this machine.
And I want to have it
available on my phone.
So now we have this project
right here on the phone.
And everything that I
showed just a moment ago
with Workspaces still works.
So let's try-- first step, we're
just going to select this text
and try a different
selection color.
Ooh yeah, that's nice--
something like that?
OK, good-- come over,
select this text, this H1.
And again, we'll change the font
size to be really big-- yeah.
And what's great about this is
that these changes that I just
made here while I'm
debugging my phone,
these just saved to disk.
So if I now come over
to my other window,
this one-- see, this
one-- I refresh.
Wow, yes-- cool.
So this means I basically can
choose where I want to develop,
and it's all saving
back to disk, which
means that I can go really fast,
make changes, and not worry
about where I have to copy what.
All right, so this is how
remote debugging works now.
We have a very
powerful feature set.
Everything that you can
do in regular developer
tools you can do while
you debug your phone--
the screen casting
feature, port forwarding.
And it's a lot easier to set
up than it ever was before.
All right, I'm going to
move on to performance.
So first up, these are actually
graphs from Internet Explorer.
They were talking about what
sorts of operations the browser
does when it's loading
and using pages.
So they looked at the top
100 sites and the top Ajax
sites, JavaScript-heavy
sites, and looked
at what the browser is
busy doing on those sites.
And in these cases, the amount
of time actually executing
JavaScript is pretty low.
A lot of time is just spent
in layout rendering and kind
of manifesting the page.
So this basically means
that JavaScript is often not
the bottleneck in
many, many cases.
And you want to be
able to look at and get
an idea of the performance
of the other parts of what
the browser has
to do, so not just
running the JavaScript profile.
So let's talk about
how some of that works.
And to show it, I'm going
to do a little demo where
I do a performance
audit of this site.
So this is a festival in Canada.
And they have a nice website.
But it could be faster.
So I loaded up the page.
And as I scrolled out--
it might be hard to see.
But it's a little--
it doesn't feel
very smooth as I'm
scrolling here.
It feels like it's stuttering.
So I'm going to take
a look at the DevTools
and see what they're
telling me about this.
So I'm going to go
to the timeline.
The timeline is where
you want to start
all of your performance
investigations.
And I'm going to
start recording.
And here we go.
So immediately, this is giving
me back a lot of information.
And what I'm seeing is a
lot of purple here, right?
And the purple, when I look,
is a lot of recalc style.
Let me raise this up just
so that everyone can see.
So recalc style in
jQuery-- OK, interesting.
So we can look at
what exactly the call
stack is that forced this.
Add class-- OK, so
we're manipulating
the class of an element.
And we come down to where the
actual application code is.
And let me just click
through on that.
And it went right here.
So the cursor is telling me
that this is where it happened.
We called toggleClass.
And we're calling toggleClass
inside the Scroll Handler.
So on every single
scroll event, we're
manipulating the class
of the HTML element.
This-- you know how
people tell you to not
touch the DOM too much?
This is usually why.
You're manipulating the
class of the HTML element.
And what it's causing is a
lot of performance problems,
all this purple here.
So let's try changing
this and fixing it.
One quick fix that we can do is
using-- instead of toggleClass,
I'm going to use an HTML5 API,
here we go, called classList.
And classList.toggle actually
has the exact same method
signature, the same
arguments, as toggleClass.
So we can just keep
that there, keep this,
and now I'm just going
to hit Command-S.
And that should just
send it immediately
to the JavaScript engine.
So now, when I come back
to Timeline, and I hit
Record again-- ahh.
OK, cool-- it's a
big change, right?
There's no more purple.
There's no more
recalculate style.
Still, there is a good amount
of green, of painting happening.
So we want to figure
out what that is.
So I'm going to go into
the DevTools settings,
and I'm going to turn on a mode
called Show Paint Rectangles.
I'm also going to turn on
Show Composited Layer Borders.
I'm going to get into what
these mean in a second,
but I just kind of want to
figure out what's happening.
OK, interesting-- so
you can see as I scroll,
there's this rectangle
above the top nav.
So it's being repainted.
Every single time I
scroll, the browser
has to re-figure out what
the top of that looks like.
You can't just put the
layers on top of each other.
It's doing a lot of work here.
I want to make that easier.
And so I'm going to
try a few tricks.
So we're going to come in here.
Here's the main navigation.
A quick tip is you can
hit H on the keyboard,
and it'll just hide
whatever element
you're looking at, all right?
So we have this top nav.
And it's actually
position fixed right?
Or-- here we go, it's position
absolute, interesting.
Let me try and see
if we can fix this.
So I'm going to change
this to position fixed.
And-- ahh, OK, here we go.
All right, position
fixed, and I'm
going to use a trick
called promoting a layer.
And you might have
seen this before.
It's often called
the translateZ(0)
or the translate3d hack.
So now I've just
promoted it to a layer.
And you can actually
see this gold border
around it-- indicates
that it's now a layer.
And now when I try
scrolling, I don't
have that red paint
rectangle around it.
And I can verify
here in the Timeline
by just scrolling
up and down-- yeah.
And I've taken care
of that concern.
This particular
trick often happens
with position fixed elements.
And right now, it's only
particular to Chrome
on desktop.
Pretty much all other browsers,
including mobile browsers,
have ways of dealing with this.
But it's something
to look out for.
All right, so those are a few
of the tricks that you can use.
But I want to walk through what
some of those operations were.
The first that you
see is recalc style.
So recalculation of style
gets all the style rules
in the document.
Whether it's in a CSS style
sheet, an in-line style,
a style tag, it
gets all of them.
And then, it looks at
what all the selectors are
and matches them
against the DOM.
It figures out what elements it
needs to evaluate the style of
and gets a computed style
of every CSS property
for every element in the DOM.
All right, once it knows what
all the styles should be,
it needs to apply it.
And this is called the layout.
Layout is the first step
where it just figures out
the geometry of where
everything goes in the document.
I want to show a problem
called layout thrashing.
Layout thrashing happens because
when a browser is laying out
the geometry of
the page, it also
needs to figure
out-- if you ask it
for the current position
or the current width,
the current size of an element,
the browser's like, oh, OK,
I'll go get that.
But then, if you change
something, it re-lays it out.
And then, there's a bad pattern
that people often fall into.
I'm going to show a little
demonstration right now.
All right, come
on-- OK, all right,
so in this little
demonstration, I
can change the size of
the green rectangle.
And when I hit Set
Block Width, it goes
and it sets the width of
all the other text blocks.
You can see-- click,
ugh, it takes a while.
Now, there's another
way to do this.
And if I try that
way-- ahh much faster.
OK, so what's the
difference between the two?
Let's open up the DevTools.
First, I'll turn off these guys.
And I'm going to start
our Timeline recording
and set that block width.
Ooh, OK, so here, you can see
that big pause, that big chunk,
after I clicked.
All right, so I'll
bring this up.
Now, you can see here, this
pattern-- recalc style layout,
recalc style layout,
recalc style layout.
And there's this little
warning indicator telling you
that there might be a problem.
And it says, "Forced
synchronous layout
is a possible
performance bottleneck."
And you can see right here
what it's telling you.
There was a layout that was
invalidated at line 125.
And the layout was forced to
be recomputed at line 124.
So let's go look at those lines.
All right, so here is line 124.
What we have is
a big while loop.
It's just looping over all
those little text blocks.
And inside that loop,
we get the offset width
of that green
block, of this guy.
And then, we come in and we
set the width of each element.
So we're setting the
width of each element.
We're going to
look into the size.
We're setting the width,
going to look into the size.
In the fast version,
which is right here,
we go and we look up the
width of that block once.
And then, we go and
we do all of our sets
where we set the widths.
So the big thing
to learn here is
that if you need to figure out
the dimensions, if you need
to ask the DOM
for the dimensions
or sizes of an element,
try and do that only once
and not interleave it
with changes that you're
making to the DOM.
But if you ever
have any question,
just open up the Timeline.
And you'll probably end
up seeing this pattern.
It happens a lot of times.
All right, the next is paint.
Painting often
captures a lot of time.
We were seeing
before all the green.
There's a lot of
time spent in paint.
There's a few ways
to debug when you're
having a lot of painting.
And the first is
Continuous Paint mode.
So Continuous Paint
mode allows you
to look at how long
it takes to paint,
and it allows you to
kind of figure out
what is contributing to it.
So I'm going to turn it on now.
You'll see right here, Enable
Continuous Page Repainting.
All right, so this is it.
What it's telling me is it's
taking about three to four
milliseconds to paint this page.
And it's just doing it
over and over again.
I can verify that down here
by opening the timeline.
All right, so what
this allows us to do
is we can make some
changes and figure out
how to kind of manipulate
what that looks like.
So I'm going to come over
and turn on some box shadows.
Wow, OK, cool, so box
shadows definitely
take a lot more time to paint.
And so that's why we're seeing
the graph really spike up.
I could also, let's see,
try-- if, for instance,
I take this box show, and right
now it has a blur radius of 120
pixels, if I just change that
down to 20 pixels, it's faster.
Bring it down even more-- yeah.
So this allows you to kind
of see what affects paint.
Oftentimes, box shadow does
currently impact paint cost
quite a lot.
But Chrome is always
improving things.
So that might not be
the same case tomorrow.
The next situation
I want to introduce
is-- we call it paint storms.
And pant storms basically
refers to the browser
is painting the page a lot.
But it really shouldn't have to.
So let's take a look at a
situation where that happens.
So I'm going to come in here
and set this background--
all right.
I'm going to come
over to Timeline
and turn off Continuous
Paint for now.
And if I turn on Show Paint
Recs, you can see-- actually,
it's a little hard to see.
But the entire
screen is repainting
on every single scroll.
We can see the paint
action down here.
It has to figure out-- let
me turn on a box shadow,
too, so it hurts even more.
Uhh, yeah, that
feels bad, right?
Ouch-- all right,
so what's happening
is that there's the fixed
background behind all
this content.
And the browser is
being really slow
in figuring out-- on
every single scroll,
it is recomputing how that looks
underneath all this content.
I'm going to quickly try
and fix this-- we'll see.
Doo, doo, doo-- I'm going to
take the fixed background that
is on the body, and I'm going
to create a brand new element.
Let's put him right here.
And I'm going to cheat.
And I have some code-- hey.
Hey, what?
No, definitely not--
OK, there we go.
So I have my div.
And let's drop in that.
OK, yeah, that
seems pretty good.
With 100% cover-- there we go.
OK, cool, now--
so I've basically
shifted the background from
the background of the body
to a div that's within it and
just put z-index as negative 1
to kind of put it
behind everything.
And I use that trick again,
the translateZ(0) trick,
because it is position fixed.
And so you can see now,
there's no red outline.
And if I look in the
timeline, there's no activity.
Just to kind of verify that
this indeed does change things,
I take off that translateZ(0).
It's back.
It's gone.
Cool, so that can be a trick
for fixed backgrounds or fixed
position elements.
But the big thing that
you want to look for
is turning on Show
Paint Rectangles
and seeing if the
entire page is flashing,
or one section of
the page is flashing,
while you're scrolling the
page, or while some behavior is
happening.
That's often a way you can--
there is some improvement
that you could make.
And you want to
investigate what you
can do there to make the
experience a lot smoother.
All right, moving forward--
I just kind of want
to point out, if you spend a
lot of time in the timeline,
you want to get a flow
for what operations
are supposed to happen.
And this is the
correct kind of flow.
So oftentimes, you'll
have JavaScript that runs.
After that, the styles
need to be recalculated.
The geometry of the page
needs to be laid out.
Maybe there's paint set-up.
We have to show what
things look like.
And then, we have
to kind of send it
to the GPU and composite
layers together.
When doing performance
work with the timeline,
this is kind of a cheat sheet
for what tool to use when.
If you profile
with the timeline,
and you're spending a
lot of time in script,
just go to the
JavaScript Profiler.
If you're spending a lot of
time in layout, look and figure
out if you have layout
thrashing, things like that.
Paint-- I covered this.
Paint recs, layer borders--
use Continuous Paint mode.
And there's a pro
level feature called
About Tracing, which dives
into the guts of Chrome,
that you can use if none of
these are working for you.
All right, but how do
these all map to CSS?
Just your general
CSS that you write--
the CSS Selector gets
recomputed in recalc style.
The height, because it's
the geometry of the element,
is what size it is
and its position.
That affects layout.
And a text shadow doesn't affect
the layout of the page at all.
It only affects how it looks.
It's a visual effect.
And so that's captured
underneath paint.
So there's actually--
between all
the different CSS
properties, they
affect different parts
of all these operations.
Transform and opacity can
be operated 100% on the GPU.
This is really good.
Basically, GPUs are
fantastic at doing
these sorts of operations.
But everything else needs to go
through a little bit more work.
Box shadow, border
radius, and background
just need to be painted.
But they don't affect
the geometry, the layout.
And like I mentioned,
width, margin, border,
those sorts of things,
those do layout.
So if you're doing an
animation, like you're
animating an item
across the page,
or you're increasing the
height of an element, the less
work that you can
do, the better.
If all you can change is just
the transform and opacity,
it's probably going to be a
lot faster than if you try
and animate left
and top or width.
So try and animate these guys.
Here's another way
to look at that.
There's four things that a
browser can transition really
fast.
They can scale, move,
rotate, and fade.
That maps over to our
transforms and our opacity.
Sometimes, you do need to
apply that translateZ(0).
Everything else that you
translate, that you animate,
might take more work.
And so just be aware of that.
Especially on older
phones, animating something
like left and top or
width is going to be slow.
So if you want things
to be fast on mobile,
try and animate
only those things.
All right, I just want
to quickly try and show
the difference of what this
looks like in the DevTools.
I have this table here.
And this is kind of
a fun little app that
lets you see how different
CSS properties animate.
It's nice.
Let's take a look
at what changes
all these things affect
in the web browser.
So we'll open up the
DevTools and come down here.
All right, so
here, we have left.
Here we have top.
We're animating the top.
And here's transform.
And if I come in,
I'm going to turn off
Show Paint Rectangles for
now and go to Timeline-- yes.
I'll do a recording.
There we go.
So here, in this
recording, you can
see we're going through
recalc style, layout, paint,
composite layers.
When I do transform--
oops-- all we're doing
is just painting and
composite layers.
And that's all the
work that we do.
Yeah, so the best ways to
do an animation, if you can,
is to not use JavaScript.
If you can do it completely in
key frame animations or a CSS
transition, browsers can
optimize that really,
really well.
Once you use jQuery to animate,
it's going to be a lot slower.
Because the browser can't
predict what's happening next.
All right, let's move on.
I was going to talk a little
bit about how to figure out
when sites are done loading.
And there's a
fantastic measurement.
And it's called the speed index.
It basically
evaluates how long it
takes to get a visual
on the page of what
the page is supposed
to look like.
It's a really nice
metric and captures
when the page has completed
loading a lot better
than window.load or
DOM content ready.
So it's called the speed index.
And right now, you can use
Web Page Test to look at it.
Web Page Test-- raise
your hand if you've
used Web Page Test before.
A few people, yeah--
it's really fantastic.
So I'm going to show quickly
what the results look like.
So I did an analysis for
a site called RetailMeNot.
And in it, you get
the network waterfall.
But a really nice view
is the film strip view
where you can see
this network waterfall
against the visual
representation.
So I can scroll and
kind of see as resources
were loaded what did
the page look like.
And here, at 0.9 seconds, we
finally got to see something.
It can also capture what the
Chrome DevTools Timeline will
look like for this
exact recording.
The Chrome DevTools
is a web app.
So we can just load up
the Chrome DevTools using
that recording and see if we
see any of those patterns.
Big layout, timers-- yeah,
this site was really fast,
so there's not much optimize.
And lastly, they also do Show
and Capture the Speed Index.
So a really nice
thing that you can do
is have Web Page Test track
the performance of your page.
Do a test once a day, and you
can see its progress over time,
and see if you're
actually improving
how fast that page loads.
It's possible to run a
completely private instance.
You can send it.
You can ask a Chrome or
an IE8 or IE9 in the cloud
to evaluate the page.
Or you can also
run it internally
if you want to evaluate
it against a site that's
in development.
All right, so to sum up, users
expect things to be fast.
Under 100 milliseconds
is good for showing
a user that it's happening.
But it starts to
get really stuttery
when it comes to animation.
Anything longer than
one second is just
going to take way too long.
So you want to be really attuned
to how fast your page loads
and how fast the
interactions are.
These are some
aggressive but good goals
to kind of think about.
When it comes to delivering
an experience on mobile,
you really want to
show the content that's
above the fold, the content that
the user sees when they first
load up the page, in under
one second from after they
click a button, click a link,
or finish typing in a URL.
Under one second is a good goal.
One of the things that has to
happen to be able to do this
is serve all the
content that you
need to for that above the
fold content in under 14K.
That includes any CSS that
is required for that section.
But if you have CSS that
applies to the rest of the page,
you can defer that and
send that part later.
Oh, well, OK, all right,
lastly-- a maximum
of 200 milliseconds
for the server
to respond with the page, 60 FPS
scrolling, 60 FPS transitions,
keep things fast, and a
speed index under 1,000.
I showed you a lot of things
in the Chrome Developer tools
today.
We have been working
on our documentation.
So this covers a lot of
the functionality that's
in there, things that
you might not expect.
So I encourage you
to go check that out.
And everything that I showed
is available in Chrome Canary
today.
And one more thing--
is Jimmy Moon here?
He is, oh good.
OK, great, hi, Jimmy.
Jimmy's awesome.
And we met actually at
Google I/O not too long ago.
He's a JavaScript
developer here in Seoul.
And he's been really active
on the Yeomen project.
He also maintains the generators
for the Chrome apps and Chrome
extensions.
And a lot of people use these.
He's also working
on a brand new site
that I encourage
you to check out.
It's called Chromist.
And he wrote about Polymer
just the other day.
And it's really fantastic.
So I encourage you
to check that out.
And I just wanted
to thank you, Jimmy,
because you're fantastic.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: And
that's it for me, too.
Thank you guys very
much-- appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]